Moin, hallo hallo hallo, exellent, möchte noch mal auf was hinweisen und zwar
das 0w eindeutig das bessere emote ist als keqw das muss immer mal wieder gesagt
wenn sonst vergessen ist die leute
ist aber komisch hier kommen nicht alle chat messages an ich habe auf meinem
vorschau monitor eine message von starbucks der sagt mau das sieht man
hier gar nicht oder ane da ist er doch da hat eine andere farbe das ist auch
fehlen dass die leute unterschiedliche farben haben je nachdem in welchem chat
du eingelogt bist es sei denn man hat seine farbe irgendwie festgelegt ich
glaube man konnte seine farbe doch in den settings festlegen weiss nicht ob ich
das gemacht habe
bauke ja seit einer stunde ungefähr schon was mit vpn kommt gar nichts an
ich bin überrascht wie in falschen rein folgen die chatnachrichten ankommen
links bei mir im chat auf dem vorschau monitor kam die messages jetzt
vertauscht an und der umut kam noch gar nicht an jetzt kam an dachte immer das
ist irc based gut ich meine im java script frontend wird das nicht irc
based sein fs.com ja das ist die das sind die die die stellen so sfp module
und sowas für switchen her aber um und hast du mir die nicht so gar mal
empfohlen also ich meine passt das zusammen erst erst erst erst sagst du
hier kauft die kauft die sind gut dann fragst du mich was ich damit will also
keine ahnung ich habe von da noch nichts gekauft was ich mir gekauft habe ist
bisher ich habe am anfang so doof und hat mir die offiziellen unify oder
ubiquity module gekauft die eigentlich viel zu teuer sind und jetzt habe ich
nur noch die mit die die rj 10 mikrotik dinger die habe ich mir mal ein 10er
pack gekauft weil die mal relativ günstig waren die gab es mal teilweise
für 35 euro oder so das stück mittlerweile kosten die glaube ich
wieder 60 oder so
auch schon mal mal ja ich habe die mal für 35 gekriegt
deswegen ist jetzt meine meine sfp plus needs erst mal gedeckt dadurch dass ich
mir einen 10er pack gekauft habe gut das ist nichts für optisches na das ist
sfp plus auf rj 45 warum die dinge auch immer rj 10 heißen wahrscheinlich weil
es in 45 sport ist für 10 gigabit keine ahnung
rock
irritiert mich immer noch dass die neueste obs version wenn man streamt
auch diesen roten punkt hat normalerweise hatte obs immer nur diesen
roten punkten ein rekord drückt jetzt denke ich immer ich habe aus versehen
aufgenommen und meine ssd ist bald voll oder sowas
habt ihr so grob verfolgt was der hacker mäßig in russland und ukraine so
abgeht von fernsehsendern die irgendwelche videos ausstrahlen bis zu
irgendwelchen kraftwerken wo die steuerung jetzt im internet ist da geht
es richtig zur sache
ansonsten ansonsten muss ich ehrlich sagen verfolge ich den kram nur am rande
weil es weil das ist ich da muss man sich da ist vier mit sicherheit
sicherheit ist da viel fake dabei aktuell kann ja keiner auch so wirklich
stichhaltig überprüfen was stimmt was nicht wie willst du das auch machen aber
da ist so viel so viel abgedrehter kram dabei wenn nur ein bruchteil davon war
ist dann geht auf jeden fall ordentlich was ab
das kannst du aktuell nicht gescheite überprüfen ist eh schwierig ich habe
eh meine eh meine probleme auf fotos zu erkennen wer wer ist was also fotos
schwachsinn auf auf videos eins muss man ja mal sagen ich glaube das ist
damit abstand best gefilmte best dokumentierte krieg aller Zeiten es gab
halt im westen saß aber so grob im westen seit smartphone kein krieg mehr
seit smartphone start und nachdem jeder jetzt mit einer 4 bis 8k bis 120 fps
kamera rum läuft wird alles mögliche auf aufgenommen
da kannst du dir angucken wie irgendwie das ist das ist quasi krieg 3.0 sozusagen
kannst du dir angucken in slow motion weil es jemand mit 120 fps aufgenommen
hat wie irgendeine abwehr rakete den panzer trifft und so was
also das ist schon also man sieht das jetzt so gut und in so
hoher qualität wie noch nie zuvor
moin taste ansonsten muss ich ehrlich sagen verfolge ich den kram nur
absichtlich am rande ich gucke da ich lese einmal am tag drüber weil ich das
ist ein sehr deprimierendes thema es gibt genug videos in richtig guter quali
man hat nicht jeder super super 8k smartphone
ja gibt es ja jede menge sagt mörb dankeschön für den zapp
vor aller 5 stunden playlist lull ebola und danke für den zapp 27 poggers monats also kann ich nur sagen
dass sie maut findet ring passes ab screamer dort ja
Ich bin eher erstaunt, wie entspannt die Leute da teilweise rumstehen und filmen, während
die Leute sich daran gewöhnt haben, dass nichts passiert, obwohl man vielleicht besser wegrennen
sollte.
Der hat gesagt, nein er will nicht evakuiert werden, er will Panzerabwehrraketen haben oder
sowas in der Richtung.
Oh man, es gab doch auch letztens dieses, das war glaube ich gar kein Video, das waren
so paar Fotos, wo irgendein Typ im Wald eine verlassene russische Luftabwehr gefunden
hat und sich gedacht, da nehme ich jetzt mal mit, oh man, das kann man immer gebrauchen.
Also dass die Leute da teilweise stehen bleiben und filmen, aber ich glaube man hat sich einfach
so dran gewöhnt, wenn was passiert, stehen bleiben und filmen.
Nach dem Autos passiert was, Handy raus, erst mal Kamera angemacht, man denkt erst in zweiter
Instanz so quasi dran, vielleicht soll ich mich mal in Sicherheit bringen.
Ja genau das meine ich, zumindest eins habe ich gesehen, man hätte Heckler und Koch Aktien
kaufen müssen, Big Stonks, zumindest kurzzeitig, guckt euch das mal an und jetzt wieder ein
bisschen runter.
Aber es war klar, Rheinmetall auch, ja wie gesagt Rheinmetall, Rheinmetall auch, naja,
gut jetzt zu angenehmeren Themen, ne das kannst du bei den meisten Sachen nicht überprüfen,
du kannst eh sehr wenig da aktuell überprüfen, ganz bestimmt, aber erst mal Leute bannen,
ja das stimmt schon, das wäre wichtig, man sieht es halt nicht, aber das könnte auch
sonst wie 5 Jahre her sein, da erkenne ich es dem Video eigentlich an, so also was gucken
wir uns denn jetzt an, ich habe zu viele Tabs auf, ich weiß gar nicht wo ich hin muss,
alter guckt euch das mal, das ist doch nicht normal, warum habe ich so viele Tabs auf,
ich weiß gar nicht, aber ich habe so viele Tabs auf, ich weiß gar nicht wo ich hin muss,
aber ich habe so viele Tabs auf, ich weiß gar nicht wo ich hin muss, aber ich habe so
viele Tabs auf, ich weiß gar nicht wo ich hin muss, aber ich habe so viele Tabs auf,
wie viel in java programmiert ist in china wahnsinn
ich habe keine ahnung was das sein soll noch nie gehört aber javascript wahrscheinlich
javascript
clonewa
China Chinesen Zeug China Chinesen Zeug
daisy ui das habe ich mir mal angeguckt das ist svel css zeug das fand ich jetzt vom designer
nicht so schön steam deck ist rausgekommen ja hat mich auch wenig geschockt muss ich ehrlich
sagen langweilig langweilig china chinesen java was sonst halo ok was haben die chinesen
mit halo zu tun pack aha aha pet jar ich glaube nicht dass es was mit halo zu tun hat
also nicht mit dem spiel sondern keine ahnung mit china chinesen kram ich habe keine ahnung
was es sein soll kann man nicht mal google translate machen google translate website
man konnte auch die ganze website übersetzen irgendwie ne wie ging das nochmal hatte man
nicht websites hier ok sie nein nein nein nicht französisch deutsch ein modernes open
source blog cm aha halo entwickler heiligenschein ja gut halo es ist halt so ein ring so ein
das was die überm kopf teilweise schwere heiligenschein ja das passt ja ganz gut ok
das ist irgendein china chinesen cms in java hacken alles klar ok code editor in rust der
wie viel der rust editor ist das bitteschön jetzt der nach ein zwei jahren nicht mehr
weiterentwickelt wird ja den meinen das gibt es ist glaube ich eher für den fall der fälle
wo man einfach was ist denn druid für den fall der fälle dass man sagt hey guck mal
kann alles in rust machen also ich muss ja mal ehrlich sagen die steuerelemente sehen
pot hässlich aus aber richtig das kann es doch keinem so zeigen na gut wahrscheinlich
kann man das schöner machen gut wir wissen dass nichts spannendes pickets autocomplete
picket autocomplete zu meinem terminal das net von fick jetzt mal mal was anderes warum
kann man nicht einfach tab drücken also ist das ist das für die für die für die für
die summa autocomplete generation dass man da das das ist jetzt das tap ist tap ist plaudit
oder was tap drücken weil eine ordentliche bash autocomplete mit tap macht exakt das
nur halt nicht in so einem pop-up ok keine ahnung ach ja der tägliche battlefield check
immer noch richtig mies und jetzt gleich noch mal das andere wie siehts wie siehts mit in
hier aus new world so schlecht so fähig not stonks also wenn das hier nicht der beste
der beste not stonks craft ist dann weiß ich auch nicht 29.000 sogar nur das ist dead das
ist einfach einfach hinüber ja es gibt jetzt ein scoreboard hat kein mensch gejuckt ja
guck mal das letzte update es hat einfach nichts es hat einfach gar nichts gemacht das
hier ist eher das ist halt das wochenende jetzt das das letzte update hat einfach gar
nichts nicht auszumachen new world vorhersehbar ja leider leider lost ark ist glaube ich immer
noch relativ beliebt wobei ich denke dass es ein bisschen nach lässt jetzt mit der zeit
ja das ist von einer million runter aber das ist immer noch ziemlich gut die werden
fett michael transactions verkauft haben ja mit sicherheit bestimmt bestimmt hast du
kinder bzw wirst du ob ich irgendwann mal haben welche haben werde kann ich jetzt ja
noch nicht abschätzen aktuell bin ich nicht scharf drauf und ich habe auch keine aber
man weiß ja nie da vielleicht denke ich mir ja so in keine ahnung vier fünf jahren wenn
ich mal wobei es gar nicht mehr wenn ich dann mal 40 plus bin dann denke ich mir vielleicht
ja irgendwann soll es wird auch langsamer zeit ja ich weiß ich bin ich bin sieben nein
ich bin 37 und und dazu das kommt natürlich dabei man braucht auch jemand dafür und man
braucht jemand mit dem man das angehen will ja und da da mangels ja an mehreren fronten
zur zeit dementsprechend ist das auch auf absehbare zeit erst mal nicht geplant und
ich kann mir nichts nervigeres vorstellen als keiner zu haben aber ok dann ist eh vorbei
aktuell kann ich ja noch relativ viel machen auf was ich bock habe neben arbeiten wenn ich
keine habe es vorbei dann ist f was schon ein scam diese neu ja ja also was ich halt
interessant fände ist dass vieles was heute so durchgeht sei es sowas wie cyberpunk oder
oder fallout 76 oder enten oder wolzen als ich noch jemanden volzen erinnert oder
bennett 22 das werden so dinger gewesen hätte man das rausgebracht vor längerer zeit
die hätten quasi dicht machen können von denen hätte nie wieder einer was gekauft
und die wären monatelang zerrissen worden von allen zeitschriften und all was es so
gibt und die hätten sich wahrscheinlich sogar geschämt für enten 2.0 ist endgültig dead
oder schon seit 2 jahren wir haben noch nicht mal angefangen so was schauen wir uns jetzt
an gunter peterson interview sehen wir uns hier plus plus nein das eine video war witzig
von dem die andere naja dass das java script developer der war nicht schlecht ist cyberpunk
inzwischen in einem guten zustand ja ich weiß es nicht hab es nicht ausprobiert aber wisst
ihr was ich versuche ja manchmal auch an so kompletten fehlendingern sowas positives
zu sehen wisst ihr was ich mir vorstellen könnte dass dadurch dass cyberpunk das hatte
immer noch fettkohle gemacht auch wegen vorbestellungen sowas aber ich könnte mir vorstellen dass
das schlechte zustand von cyberpunk und den sag mal unter untertroffenen erwartungen dafür
sorgen dass wir vielleicht in witcher 4 bekommen und das vielleicht sogar schneller als es
anderweitig der fall gewesen wäre schon entwill walt sagt mir gar nichts
auf monkaS musik spoder ich muss dir sagen ich hab bis jetzt einen großen bogen um cyberpunk
gemacht ich hatte es von anfang an nicht vor mir zu kaufen weil ich ehrlich gesagt mit
dem setting gar nichts anfangen kann und danach erst recht einen großen bogen gemacht als
ich gehört habe in welchem kacken zustand des games
ich finde das hover preview gar nicht schlecht
meinung zu apples ultra cpu mir nicht angeguckt komplett ignoriert alles von apple in letzten
wochen achso nun gut was schauen wir uns denn jetzt an
animating kirby using powerpoint moment das habe ich vorhin schon aufgemacht sack
vor allem warum powerpoint
was hat er in powerpoint gemacht
tatsächlich gut animieren muss man allerdings sagen ist was anderes
weil er hat ja quasi fertige sprites fertige bildchen genommen und die einfach nur der
reihe nach abgespielt in powerpoint ja ok man kann es meinetwegen animieren nennen
warum man das in powerpoint macht weil es geht
ich glaube tieferen sen hat es nicht
wait warum siehst du dislikes weil ich return youtube dislikes installiert habe
bei dimitri selivanov alles klar
und community ja guck das hat sogar ein shithub ein shithub repo
einfach läppische 8,6 k
ok also die leute die diese extension installiert haben und disliken wird hochgerechnet auf
die viewer anzahl oder sowas ja das ist nicht sonderlich genau aber es ist zumindest schon
mal ein so grober hinweis bei videos im die viele views und viele dislikes haben
echt ich habe die ritme jetzt gar nicht mehr angeguckt warum
ist doch alles in ordnung
das bild finde ich immer noch mega geil
baumeister doch doch das funktioniert sicherlich weiterhin
es ist ja ein obsource projekt und wahrscheinlich kann man den kram auch irgendwo anders hausten
falls es überhaupt in russland gehaustet ist
so also was schauen wir uns denn jetzt an
schule für immer das verdient ein verabbeamteter lehrer an der realschule
eins ist klar wahrscheinlich nicht genug
anscheinend wahrscheinlich nicht genug weil ich würde es echt nicht mal für sehr viel
geld machen
wo ist denn levelcap wir müssen es levelcap jebaiten lassen immer mal wieder anfangen
des streams
levelcap jebaiten world war 3 vs battlefield naja gut das haben wir uns ja gestern angeguckt
battlefield ist ungefähr bei 3000 spielern world war 3 auch
komm wir lassen uns eine runde levelcap jebaiten
ist echt so ich würde ich würde nie freiwillig lehrer werden
jetzt können wir doch mal ausprobieren leute wir schauen uns mal meine dislikes an
wir überprüfen das mal gucken wir mal
also das darf nicht wahr sein
übrigens dieses video wurde demonetized wahrscheinlich weil ich zu oft das pornwort gesagt habe
dabei ist ja absolut nichts wie soll ich sagen nichts anstößliches an diesem video aber
naja gut ok vielleicht die emojis das war es dann aber auch
so das waren 32 dislikes ich schaue mal kurz bei mir auf youtube
uploads
ich bin mit dem falschen account eingeloggt kann das sein
ich bin mit dem falschen account eingeloggt ok youtube also das meint 21000 google konto
verwalten
ich will mein google account switchen mensch
kann doch nicht so schwer sein alter
also jetzt bin ich eingeloggt ok youtube studio
so inhalt ist ja die kram auf deutsch monka es also ich habe auf diesem video also die
mein 21 2100 tausend daumen hoch und 32 stauben runter und ich habe sieht man das jetzt überhaupt
ich weiß gar nicht wo ich die likes dislikes überhaupt sehe
reichweite interaktion wo sehe ich denn jetzt überhaupt die dislikes
ist ja auch geil danke youtube danke top sehr gut habt ihr habt ihr ganz toll gemacht
ah hey das ist echt genau es ist echt genau also das video hat in wirklichkeit 2135 daumen
hoch und 38 daumen runter das ist auch bei meinen videos ziemlich genau
das ist das ist viel viel besser als ich gedacht habe
das ist viel genauer als gedacht jetzt muss ich jetzt noch mal überprüfen nehmen wir
mal ein video wo nicht so viele geguckt haben gehen wir mal
habe ich irgendwas mit unter 20.000 hier
oh nein das video ok das da ach sagt 28
so das sagt 28 analytics
jetzt hat sich wieder ausgelockt das video hat 32 daumen runter
krass das ist wirklich sehr sehr nah an der realität
ja da gab es die api noch das stimmt aber aber hier gab es die api definitiv nicht
mehr trotzdem das ist echt genau das hätte ich
nicht gedacht noch einmal noch einmal den vergleich hier
gab es die api auch nicht mehr 100 100 der sagt 114 114 daumen runter
das waren die die gekränkten battlefield fanboys und in wirklichkeit sind 120 leute
das ist verdammt genau dieses plugin ich weiß nicht wie fife hätte ich die das die das
machen aber das ist echt gut also wer es noch nicht
hat return youtube dislikes
krass hätte ich das das hätte ich wirklich nicht gedacht dass es so nah an der realität
dran ist ja stimmt ja ich kann es aber nicht
vergleichen wie es bei anderen videos aussieht weil bei anderen videos habe ich ja kein
analytik zugriff okay wir lassen uns einmal
das kann durchaus sein dass auch noch die stimmung dass du auch noch die stimmung der
kommentare analysiert wird das könnte ich mir sehr gut vorstellen du kannst ja
heute ai technisch wirklich verdammt also wirklich extrem fife hädiges zeug machen
ich habe letztens in artikel gelesen über irgendeinen über irgendeinen experimentellen
bilder erkennungs algorithmus von google kap war von google und der war auch also erstaunlich
gut was er erkannte also spricht dem hat man bilder gegeben was weiß ich fußball auf
wiese und dann hat das plugin gesagt hier sieht man rasen mit einem ball oder sowas
in der richtung und das war ziemlich gut was ich was man aber was man aber gesehen hat
hat das auch gegen geprüft das ist nice was man aber gesehen hat ist wenn das wenn die
ai falsch gelegen hat mit dem bild war das so richtig falsch ja zum beispiel zum beispiel
ich denke mir jetzt mal irgendwas aus keine ahnung du hast jemand auf der luftmatratze
nehmen muss man noch abgedeckt du hast ein wahl im mehr gesehen oder sowas und die das
die ai sagt dann sowas wie alte frau auf terrasse oder sowas also wenn das verwendet
das falsch gelegen hat dann meistens meilenweit ansonsten war es so würde ich sagen die beschreibung
waren so so 80 90 prozent eigentlich ganz gut da stand dann nicht ein fußball auf dem
fußballfeld sondern da stand dann sowas wie ball auf der wiese oder ball auf dem rasen
oder sowas aber war schon ziemlich gut
ich würde dich wundern wenn das manche seiten sogar machen du kannst dir relativ viel kleinseitig
machen javascript technisch ich erinnere nur mal an die webseite von cristiano ronaldo
die kryptowährung gemeint hat in javascript wobei da wahrscheinlich cristiano ronaldo
weniger dafür konnte sondern eher der admin wie hieß das dislike addon genau das heißt
das heißt return youtube dislikes und du kannst hier guck mal anarios return youtube dislikes
da kommst du auf die offizielle github seite und da hast du irgendwo wahrscheinlich auch
links zum store oder so und immer dran denken den kram nur aus dem offiziellen store installieren
hier zur firefox gibt es für chrome was mit safari braucht keiner safari ist eh bloated
oh schau mal weiter also levelcap gbade uns
ich muss ja sagen dieses scoreboard an sich das ist gar nicht immer so schlecht gemacht
das ist durchaus in ordnung was ich halt sehr fehl finde ist dass du es am ende der runde
nicht einblenden kannst und sowas die sache ist nur die das rettet das spiel halt nicht
die leute spielen das spiel weil das also spiel das spiel nicht mehr weil das game langweilig
ist und weil das game nicht ihre erwartung erfüllt hat dass jetzt die erwartung nicht
erfüllt wurden war ein kleiner teil davon das scoreboard ja was dann im endeffekt bei
vielen leuten noch mal so untermauert hat so nach dem oder da ist kein plan mehr was sie
machen aber ansonsten ist das scoreboard gar nicht
schlecht die level fehlen ja das kann doch nicht sein guck mal stell dir mal vor wisst
ihr wisst ihr was das für psychische psychischen druck auslösen würde wenn man die level sehen
würde da würde man ja sehen jemand anderes hat ein höheres level als man selbst das
ist nicht also das geht nicht das kannst du nicht machen heutzutage wenn man das sieht
dann dann sind die leute ja schon wieder instant kurz vorm aninstall und fühlen sich getriggert
und und shitstorm auf twitter weil das nicht positiv genug ist oder so keine ahnung das
ist wahrscheinlich absicht dass es nicht drin ist also dieser trailer dieser trailer hat
uns alle so heftig gebadet können wir euch noch an den stream im lost erinnern wo wir
beide von komplett aus geflippt sind und ja
zu dem game ist certainly welcome die general reception aber zum glück haben wir uns damals
noch die hintertür offen gelassen haben gesagt am ende kann sich immer noch wie kacke spielen
und ja das spielt sich am ende auf die kacke
wisst ihr wisst ihr was das was das witzige daran ist wenn man sich die spielzahl anguckt
wenn sie sind worden rauskommt es ist niemand mehr da um sie sind worden zu spielen
8 for what many believe our central editions to keep the game online indy tactical fps world
war three also received a critical update this weekend before we get into that update i've
got a quick word from today's sponsor if you're a guy you have a quick word but also ich
dachte dass sie es ich dachte ein drittel des videos is sponsoring a two out of three chance
of experiencing hair loss by the age 35 and it can be tough losing what makes you look
like you the good news is today machen wir einshaft jetzt schon werbung für anti haar
aus fallprodukte ok warum nicht ich mein die leute die da gucken der wird geguckt haben
demo demografie heißt es glaubt in seinem channel analytics und die haben gesagt passt
wunderbar und das ist das ist im prinzip wie bei mir bei mir würde das auch gut passen
leute ich guck mal kurz analytics ratet mal leute in welchen in welchen altersgruppen ich
die meisten zuschauer habe also es gibt altersgruppen ich sage euch das es gibt altersgruppen 13 bis
17 18 bis 24 25 bis 34 35 bis 44 45 bis 54 raten wir wo ich die meisten zuschauer oder
die oder die die meiste insgesamt so in wurde wo die meist 3524 ihr seid gar nicht schlecht
leute korrekt ich habe 13 bis 17 jährige habe ich zu gut wie gar nichts aber das liegt daran
dass die leute sich wahrscheinlich auf youtube mit fake accounts anmelden weil die viele
Sachen soll sich sehen dürfen. Ich glaube kaum ein Channel hat wirklich viele 13 bis 17-jährige.
So, dann habe ich 18 bis 24, 40% also 39,3%, 25 bis 34, 40,8%, 35 bis 44, 14% und 45 bis 54,
4,1% und es sind 99% männlich, 0,9% weiblich und 0,1% nutzerspezifisch.
Aha, wahrscheinlich kann man den Account öfters mal umschalten dann. Oder Account mit mehreren
Nutzern oder was auch immer uns das sagen soll, ich weiß es nicht. So und ich gehe davon aus,
dass es bei Levelcap ähnlich ist und dementsprechend ist das eigentlich das
beste Placement, was du als so H-Ausfallprodukthersteller machen kannst,
denn es betrifft die Leute, sagen wir mal grob, das ist grob die Gruppe quasi von 18 bis 34 oder 18 bis
44 da. Also da wo der Großteil guckt, das ist eigentlich Big Brain Sponsoring das so zu machen.
Da steht 0,9. Wie viele Fake Accounts das sind? Keine Ahnung. Ich sag 18 bis 44,
natürlich fängt es bei den Leuten nicht an mit 18 direkt kahl zu sein. Was ist denn, was ist denn,
was ist denn FDA approved? Ist das irgendeine Ami Behörde oder so? Die haben doch, die stehen
auch so auf drei Buchstabenabkürzungen. Also ich hab auch nicht mehr das aller vollste Haar,
ja? Also für mich wäre das auch was. Die Sache ist plus die, dass diese Dinger alle nicht helfen.
Nichts hilft bei H-Ausfall. Das Einzige, was wohl wahrscheinlich hilft ist, wenn du frühzeitig
anfängst irgendwelche Produkte zu verwenden, aber dann musst du quasi anfangen zu einer Zeit,
wo du dir noch überhaupt keine Gedanken machst um H-Ausfall. Also du kannst, du musst dann
quasi mit 15 anfangen versus H-Ausfall vorzubeugen und das macht ja keiner. Haartransplantation in
der Türkei. Warum in der Türkei? Ist da billiger oder wie? Mein Nachbar, mein Nachbar hat eine
Haartransplantation gemacht. Fällt mir so grad mal der Gelegenheit ein. Der hat aber noch
wenige Haare gehabt als ich. Also der ist ungefähr so alt wie ich. Und das ist verbreiteter als man denkt.
Warum, warum exakt prügelt er im Hintergrund eigentlich jetzt rum, wenn H-Ausfall und so.
Hat er nicht eben gesagt, you can't crow back what you lost? Da wollen sie uns aber
wieder das Gegenteil weismachen oder? Wahrscheinlich haben sie ihn einfach nur anders gecampt. Ja
natürlich. Alles klar, alles klar. Also entweder haben die den einfach nur sehr geschickt gecampt,
länger wachsen lassen und dann drüber gecampt oder es ist ganz harter Chebat. Ist das überhaupt
der gleiche Dude? US Army und hier keine Ahnung. Ist das überhaupt der gleiche Dude? Ich meine es
sieht ähnlich aus, aber aus diesem Winkel machen keine Ahnung. Ich trau denen alles zu. Was die Nase
beim rechten war doch viel dünner. Okay, das muss ich jetzt mal schnell überprüfen. Ja das könnte
auch am Winkel liegen. Hier ist man halt weiter oben auf dem Kopf und hier mehr von vorne. Ich
meine das hier sieht schon sehr ähnlich aus, aber ganz ehrlich, ich habe keine Ahnung ob es der
gleiche Dude ist. Das Audio in diesem Game müssen die auch überarbeiten. Sekunde Leute mal, wer das
Audio in diesem in diesem Game nicht kennt. Wir haben das ja kurz gespielt. Passt mal auf,
das Audio in diesem Game in Autos. Das ist das schlechteste Audio, was ich je. Ja ja Max ist gut.
Wo fahre ich denn Panzer? Am Ende fahre ich ein bisschen Panzer. Oh nee, danach haben wir
Battlefield gespielt. Panzer, wo bin ich Panzer gefahren? Das Sound war so schlecht. Ja hier,
das Archiv ist broken. 125. Mich würde es sogar nicht wundern, wenn die sich nicht da
sogar irgendwo hätten inspirieren lassen. Das Archiv ist slow. Passt mal auf, ihr müsst euch den
Panzer Sound anhören, der ist dermaßen schlecht. Man beachte, bester Player Name. Was mache ich
da jetzt? Hör doch, habt ihr es gehört? Ihr sind auf jeden Fall keine Gegner. Das hört sich an,
als ist einer in die Garage von seinem Opa gegangen und haut zwei Klötze aufeinander.
Schussgefühl der Dinger ist Pains Champ. Hört ihr das? Das ist so schlecht. Okay,
Schussgefühl der Dinger ist Pains Champ. Also der Sound, was ich damit sage, der war wirklich,
wirklich schlecht. Damit hätten die im Leben nicht gerechnet, dass sie ähnlich viele Spieler
haben wie das neue Battlefield. Die Sache ist plus die, es ist halt wenig Spieler, aber die sind im
Playtest, also vielleicht kriegen sie es gebacken. Auf der anderen Seite, das Spiel kam ja schon mal
vor drei Jahren oder so raus und ist dann in der Versenkung verschwunden. Also ob die es diesmal zu
einem richtigen Knaller machen, ich weiß nicht. Übrigens, das Beste ist, das muss ich euch an der
Stelle auch nochmal zeigen wollen, ich habe sogar ein Video dazu gemacht, das Beste sind die Texturen
auf der Map. Passt mal auf, das müsst ihr sehen, das ist aus, mitten, mitten aus Berlin Tag und Nacht
hier. Ja, gleich, gleich, gleich. Guckt mal, jetzt, jetzt. Max, guck um die Ecke, pass mal auf. Nein,
nicht zurücklaufen. Nein, um die Ecke gucken, in die andere Richtung, Max. Genau, genau, genau.
Okay, Gegner killen, ja. Max, du musst aus dem Ding jetzt raus und nach rechts gucken, da ist das
Plakat, was ich euch zeigen will. Okay, Ecken, Ecken, Corner stellt. Mensch, Max, lauft doch mal um die
Ecke. Okay, Heil Champ, Max, du Boss. Mensch, Max, lauft um die Ecke. Ich muss die Pistel rausholen,
ich guck mir das mit der Pistole an. Hier, hier, jetzt. Pistel. Und jetzt in die andere Richtung.
Jetzt. Das Arbeitsamt ist im Game. Das Arbeitsamt ist im Spiel. Ich sag doch, mitten aus dem Leben,
die Texturen in diesem Spiel. Gameplay commentary mit AI generieren, das wäre auch mal was. Die
scheinen wohl wirklich entweder echt dahingefahren zu sein und das fotografiert haben oder die haben
sich einfach Anzeigen im Internet genommen und das da rein gehauen. Das, das, das fand ich
lustig, dass das da drin ist. Okay, weiter Level Capture Baiten. Oder Google Bild. Street View, gute Idee.
Leute, Street View ist wieder in Deutschland unterwegs. Ich habe letztens ein Google Street
View Auto gesehen bei uns. Um die Ecke. Street View ist anscheinend wieder unterwegs. Mal schauen,
ob es dazu News gibt. Also das hat mich überrascht, weil Google hat ja gesagt, sie wollen nicht mehr
in Deutschland Street View fotografieren. Zu aufwendig war, weil sich zu viele Leute beschwert
haben und geschwärzt werden mussten oder alles. Was? Oh, please. Warzone Mobile.
Was kommt zuerst raus? Diablo Immortal oder Warzone Mobile? Okay, wir wissen es alle. Warzone Mobile
wahrscheinlich. Ich habe noch nie gehört. Ich habe noch nie gehört.
Den traue ich zu, den traue ich zu, dass sie absichtlich da Dinger hinterlassen haben,
dass die Leute finden.
Wisst ihr was ich echt erstaunlich finde? Kann man jetzt nicht vergleichen, aber wenn man
sich Half Life 2 heute anguckt, das sieht immer noch ganz gut aus. Und das Game ist von wann?
2003 oder so? Wann ist Half Life 2? Das ist schon uralt 2004. Also Half Life 2 hatte echt
eine Optik, die gut gealtert ist. Selbst wenn du dir Review Screenshots anguckst,
aus vom Release. Ja, das wurde mittlerweile mehrfach geupdatet, aber das sah wirklich
damals schon brauchbar aus. Im Gegensatz zu Half Life 1. Aber in diesen fünf Jahren,
oder es sind ja eigentlich sechs Jahre mehr oder weniger, 1998 bis 2004, also technisch ist glaube
ich nie wieder so viel passiert wie in dieser Zeit. 1998 bis 2004. Das ist Wahnsinn. Da haben
sie Spiele entwickelt von Pixel Prey zu sieht heute noch ganz okay aus. Hier haben wir sogar mal
durchgespielt hier im Stream und ich habe mich mega nicht geführt, sondern ich wollte einfach
nur noch das ganze durchbekommen, weil das Level Design von Fear so Pains Champ ist ab der Mitte.
Ich wollte es einfach nur durchbekommen.
Warum musst du denn alles Remaken und Rebooten? Das originale Dead Space sieht immer noch top
aus, auch für heutige Zeiten. Das war so ein rundes Game, das originale Dead Space. Der Sound
war einfach mega geil. Anders geil als jetzt im Battlefield. Im Battlefield ist einfach der Sound
geil, weil sich das alles so, das zieht dich so rein in Battlefield Sounds. Der Battlefield Sound
ist Battlefield 2042 aus und vor genommen, aber der Dead Space Sound war einfach so richtig so
so ambientet drum herum richtig richtig geil. Von Rohren, Rohre die klopfen, bis Dinger die
kratzen hinten. Das war wirklich wirklich extrem gut. Also wer Dead Space 1 nicht gespielt hat,
sollte es unbedingt mal spielen. Aber ich sage euch gleich, das Game braucht doch zwischenzeitlich
relativ starke Nerven. Aber es ist wirklich nice. Also es sollte jeder mal gespielt haben.
Das sieht jetzt aber auch nicht so viel anders aus als das originale.
Das Game sieht anders aus.
Das habe ich gesehen, das habe ich gesehen, dass in jeder Menge guter Games dabei,
in 1000 Spiele ist natürlich erschlagen. Aber das sind tatsächlich einige coole Sachen.
Das darf natürlich nicht fehlen. Die müssen natürlich mitmachen. Die können nicht Elgato das
Feld überlassen mit Streaming, mit Streaming Zeug. Ist das, ist das Pokimane oder sieht die da
einfach nur ähnlich? Oh ne, das darf man nicht sagen. Sieht ihr nicht wirklich ähnlich? Die Kenner
sind im Chat. Wer war sonst?
Wahrscheinlich wird da auch ein bisschen was geflossen sein.
Moment, Moment, Moment. Jetzt haben Lego Games schon Open World. Nicht, dass es schlecht sein muss,
aber die Lego Games, das war für mich immer so der Inbegriff von linear.
Reboot. Was wird denn irgendwie nicht was Rebooted? Man hört ja nur noch Reboot,
Reimagined und sonstige Dinger, Remastered. Hat er noch irgendeine kreative Ideen um was
Neues zu machen? Freigeist, danke für den Zappen. Nö, weil sie verkacken werden. Ist es, ist es?
Leider, leider ist Battlefield 2042 so kacke geworden, dass es vielleicht die einen oder
anderen Spieler noch hält. Ich bin mal gespannt. Ich würde es ihnen gönnen, aber ich glaube es
nicht, nachdem sie sich da schon mal nicht mit rumbekleckert haben.
Das habe ich nicht mitbekommen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was da passiert ist.
Ah, ah, haben wir auf Steuer hinterzogen, okay.
Aha, okay. Na dann. Ich habe von denen noch nie was gehört, keine Ahnung, kann ich nichts
zu sagen? Ist mir neu. Nein, wir haben uns fertig gibaten lassen. Das ist es. Das wollten wir doch
alle. Okay, er zeigt uns wahrscheinlich das Scoreboard und sagt, das wird nichts mehr,
das muss man sich angucken. Hat er recht. Legomotorlifts 100 Kilogramm. Alles nur eine
Frage der Übersetzung. Stryker 95, danke für den Sub. Ach so, du hast vorhin auch noch irgendwas
geschrieben, habe ich gesehen. Nee, das ist nicht besser. Nur weil das ein in die Hose geht,
heißt es ja nicht automatisch, dass jegliche anderen Reboots, Remastered, Reimagined Schiss
jetzt ganz super toll ist. Sie haben auch nicht mal versucht, Battlefield neu zu erfinden. Hätten
die versucht, Battlefield neu zu erfinden, dann hätten sie ja wenigstens ordentliche Ideen haben
müssen, was sie nicht hatten für 2042. Sie haben einfach versucht, ein Battlefield zu machen aus
einem Game, was eigentlich im Kern kein Battlefield ist. Stryker hat irgendwas zum MikroTik-Router
geschrieben. Ach so, hier, danke für den Hinweis mit dem MikroTik-Router-Switch. Ja, die sind
richtig nice. Auch preisleistungsmäßig sind die ziemlich gut. Man muss aber halt wissen,
was man haben will. Also als Fritzbox-Ersatz sind die natürlich nix. Weiß ich nicht. Vielleicht
hast du deinen Prime-Sub schon eingelöst irgendwo anders oder vielleicht ist dein Prime-Sub noch
nicht reaktiviert, weil es einen Monat Downtime hat, nachdem du mal subscribst. Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Kein Schimmer. Vielleicht buggt Amazon auch rum. Ich weiß es nicht. Lukizu, danke für den Sub.
Leute, ich hab, glaube ich, ganz viele Subscriptions übersehen. Creator Dashboard.
Stryker, danke schön. Freigeist am Start. Den Rest hab ich gesehen. Möb, weiß ich,
ob ich gesehen hab. Danke für den Sub. Monopol, gestern hab ich nicht gesehen.
Hab ich die Hälfte übersehen. War das jetzt? 100 Bits. Danke schön, Wolle. Ich kann mich
schon gar nicht mehr an den Bit-Sound erinnern. Null. So, was gucken wir uns als nächstes an?
Lass mal kurz schauen. Hast du eigentlich jemals überlegt dich selbstständig? Ja, bin ich
ja zum Teil. Ich hab ja eine eigene Firma damals angemeldet für meinen YouTube-Krempel. Natürlich
ist es jetzt nicht so, dass ich damit meinen kompletten Lebensunterhalt verdiene oder so.
Ich könnte krasse IT-Consultant werden, weil wenn ich mir angucke, wie wenig Ahnung die meisten
IT-Consultants haben, könnte ich einfach auch mit wenig Ahnung, mit etwas mehr Ahnung in
manchen Bereichen vielleicht etwas reißen, keine Ahnung. Nein, würde ich nicht machen,
hätte ich keinen Bock drauf. Da muss man sich in so viel Scheiß selbst kümmern. Ich
bin faul as fuck, was so was angeht. Dann weiß ich auch nicht, keine Ahnung, was mit
deinem Prime-Sub ist. Erstmal Amazon ankacken. Sagen, what the fuck, Amazon, Peter Aguilé
Consulting GmbH. Nee, ich würde mich wirklich Keg W Consulting nennen oder so was. Ich
weiß nicht, ich mein, die vier Buchstaben hintereinander, Keg W, das kann doch nicht
geschützt sein, oder? Der Patrick hat mich schon konsultet. Ich habe quasi mein erstes
Freelancer-Money verdient. Ich würde mich Keg W Consulting nennen. Apples in fünf Buchstaben,
das ist wohl wahr. So, weiter im Text. Wo sind wir stehen geblieben? Schule für immer,
das verdient ein verbeamteter Lehrer. Das ist cringe, ich will das nicht gucken, weil
Kinder sind immer so peinlich, alter, nervig vor allem. Okay, wir gucken uns das an. Ich
sag euch eins, egal wie viel der Typ verdient, ich würde nicht mit ihm tauschen wollen und
ich würde es garantiert niemals machen. Also die könnten, du bist peinlich, ja das stimmt,
ich weiß nicht, ich bin cringe, alter cringe. Egal was der verdient, ich würde das nicht
machen wollen. Also die könnten dem 5 Millionen im Monat bezahlen und ich würde es nicht
machen wollen. Auf der anderen Seite, bei den Beträgen würde ich mir überlegen, ob
ich den doch irgendwie mache. Würde ich dann irgendwie mir was überlegen, dass ich möglichst
wenig mich mit den Kindern oder den Jugendlichen interagieren muss. Dann müsste ich das ja
nur einen Monat machen und dann wäre ich reich, aber ist ja nicht so. Kinder sind cringe,
ja, ich bin auch richtig cringe, wenn man sich das mal überlegt. Ich bin 37, sitz sonntags
vorm Rechner und sage so Sachen wie Kekweh. Wenn das nicht cringe ist, dann weiß ich
auch nicht. Oder das ist doch eine Painz-Champ, dann reicht cringe nicht mehr aus. Cringe.
Und ich sage Sachen wie cringe und Kekweh, genau, ja, ja, schlimm. Ich glaube es gibt
nicht viele 37-Jährige, die sonntags morgens vorm Rechner sitzen und sagen cringe, Kekweh.
Reinkommen in die Klasse und eine VHS-Kassette rein. Ne, das geht nicht. Nein, nein, nein,
nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. So einfach geht das nicht. Du brauchst erst
mal irgendeinen von deinen Schülern, der dir hilft, den Videorekorder anzuschalten mit
der VHS-Kassette. Also, es kann nicht sein, dass du das selbst machst und ich frage mich,
sind das heute in den Schulen immer noch Videorekorder oder sind die mittlerweile ein bisschen moderner?
Haben die da irgendeine, irgendeine Streaming-Geschichte dran oder sowas oder was, wo du auch vielleicht
mal was YouTube-mäßiges zeigen kannst? Also irgendwie einen PC oder irgendein Shield TV
oder Android TV oder was auch immer. Overhead-Projektor. Ich hab sogar gehört, manche Schulen haben
eine Tafel, die digital ist. Also eine Tafel, wo man dann zum Beispiel auch Bilder mal drauf
einpletten kann oder was einzeichnen kann, vergrößern kann. Also so ne, so ne, weiß
gar nicht, wie man das nennt. So ein bisschen wie den Surface, bisschen wie den Surface
Hub. SmartPort, sowas, sowas, sowas in der Richtung, ja. Aber wahrscheinlich nicht die
meisten. Die meisten haben wahrscheinlich immer noch Overhead-Projektoren. Ist das
nicht normal? Nö. Kommt nicht normal. Overhead-Projektor ist normal. So, gucken wir uns das jetzt mal
an. Alter, wenn ich die schon sehe im Hintergrund. Kinder, please. MonkaS. Weiche Teufel, Alter.
Das hab ich auch immer gemacht. Das hab ich auch immer gemacht. Das ist so fett. Ich
hab auch immer, wenn ich was sagen wollt, ich hab immer so gemacht. Richtig cringe
wieder. So. Ich bin absolut zu fliegend. Also wer sich da beschwert, der hat glaub ich
keinen Realitätsbezug. Okay, okay. Da bin ich mal gespannt. Gehen wir neu, gell? Alter,
mein Hals. Man muss so früh reinkommen, weil der Kopierer oftmals nicht so geht, wie man
sich das versteht. Kopierer, es ist immer noch 2022, haben die Lehrer immer noch Probleme
mit ihren scheiß Kopierern, man. Das war bei mir schon ein Problem. Und dann hatten
sie immer so Dinge wie, wir müssen jetzt 2,50 Euro einsammeln, dass ich das Jahr über
euch Arbeitsblätter kopieren kann und sowas. Max, er sagt, du hast keinen Realitätsbezug.
Mal gucken, was er verdient. Servus, ich bin der Sigurd Alexander, ich bin Realschullehrer
für Deutsch und Musik. Gehen wir gleich links rum. Deutsch und Musik? Genau, vielleicht
noch ganz wichtig. Okay. Er hat wahrscheinlich Germanistik oder sowas studiert, mit Lehramt,
Gedöns und musste noch irgendwas dabei machen und dann wurde es dann halt Musik. Das kann
oftmals auch ein bisschen erschreckend sein, wenn Kollegen ausfallen, da sind halt dann
die zwei, drei Freistunde, die man Tag vor Tag hat, da wieder belegt. So, Morgen. Morgen.
Genau, Laptop raus. Jetzt schaust du jetzt erstens in den Vortrag. Stundenplan. Deutsch,
Deutsch, Freistunde, Musik, Freistunde, Schu... Krass, der Typ muss nur drei Stunden unterrichten
am Tag. Okay, das würde ich vielleicht auch aushalten. Das ist eigentlich so immer das
erste, was ich mache. Mein Kürzel ist S I E für Sigurd, aber da steht Gott sei Dank
nix drin. Er muss Vertretungsplan checken. Genau. Müßt ihr auch drucken? Das hat auch
manchmal seine Macken, aber jetzt hoffen wir einfach mal, dass das funktioniert. Und beidseitig.
Das kann mir keiner erzählen, dass ein Lehrer, nachdem er das eine Weile macht, für eine
Stunde Unterricht eine Stunde Vorbereitung braucht. Never. Die packen das aus, was sie
vorbereitet haben fürs letzte Jahr oder für das Jahr davor oder wie auch immer und aktualisieren
das vielleicht irgendwann mal. Niemals, niemals machen die eine Stunde Unterricht, eine Stunde
Vorbereitung. Vielleicht ganz am Anfang. Und wir sehen schon, er druckt Gott sei Dank. Er
weiß. Es ist ja auch ein. Was ist es denn? Was ist das? Ein HP? Ein Brosa? Was ist das?
Erkennt das jemand, was das für eine Marke ist? Option? Kein Schimmer. 25 Minuten geht's
los. Dann schauen wir mal, ob alles vollständig ist. Lexmark. Lexmark. Da, Lexmark, hab ich
nur schlechte Erfahrungen gemacht. Ich würde eher sagen, dass ich wenig spare. Man hat
immer so ein bisschen an Notgeräuschen. Wenn irgendwann mal was wäre, weiß er nie. Aber
es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich jetzt ein riesiges Vermögen. Wisst ihr, was ich mache? Ich spare
aktiv gar nichts. Ich gebe wenig aus. Dementsprechend ist alles, was ich nicht ausgebe, quasi gespart.
Aber das ist eine dumme Idee, sag ich euch gleich, weil, weil wenn man sich die Inflation
aktuell anguckt, ist Geld, was rumliegt, so ziemlich das Beschissenste, was man haben
kann. Mit Oldschool getackert, ne Gelocht. Ist das Copyright und Musik? Musik war klar,
das wollte ich schon immer machen, Musik studieren. Ja, Deutsch war eher so eine zweite Lösung.
Ich hab eine Woche Religion studiert, ich war aber in keiner einzigen Vorlesung. Und
dann hab ich mich bei Deutsch eingeschrieben und das war von Anfang an recht interessant.
Okay, also was umgedreht, zuerst Musik und danach Deutsch, okay. Und dabei bin ich geblieben.
So, Morgen. Genau, dann könnte man noch nachschauen übers Handy, wer heute entschuldigt ist.
Dann kann ich hier oben meine Klasse anwählen. Dann sehen wir von 25 Leuten für eine. Genau,
also müssten 24 kommen. Ob sie pünktlich sind, das werden wir dann sehen. Kommt auf die
Bade. Zum Chemie-Saal. Das sind die beiden, die ganz rechts. Aber so war es bei mir auch.
Ich wünsche euch einen guten. Oh, das fand ich auch immer ganz schlimm. Wenn man am Anfang
sich alle hingestellt hat und wenn sich dann begrüßt hat und so, das war echt schon
Paints-Champion. Übungsstunde, aber nächste Woche geht es um was. Warte mal, warte mal.
Hatte der, das war kein Aufhörprojekte, oder? Aber so war es bei mir auch. Ja, das Tischleer-Out,
das Tischleer-Out ist wirklich komisch. Wo ist der Aufhörprojektor? Der hat tatsächlich
ein Notebook stehen und hinter sich ein Beamer. Wo, was ist denn da los? Das ist wahrscheinlich
der einzig moderne Raum an der Schule. Das haben die genommen, weil das Kamerateam da
war. Ich wünsche euch einen guten. Morgen. Setzt euch bitte. Waren wir hier? Monitor
am Start, Notebook am Start. Was ist denn das? Sind wir wirklich in Deutschland? Vielleicht
sind die auch in Österreich oder so? Heute ist Übungsstunde, aber nächste Woche geht
es um was. Nächste Woche Schulaufgabe, Donnerstag 1. 2. Stunde, Materialerörterung. Ich habe
euch eine Checkliste mitgebracht. Ich denke, das ist jetzt auch ganz gut. Wer wäre denn
mal so nett und liest? Was, was wird denn da, was wird denn da erörtert? Ich wüsste anhand
der Aufgaben noch nicht mal, was ich machen soll. Ich versuche gleich mal die Lücken
zu füllen. Die Tische sind ziemlich Pains Champ, oder? Ich glaube, das sind so super
agile Tische, dass man da verschiedene Formationen draus bilden kann, je nachdem, wie man das
haben will. Und danach hat man festgestellt, eigentlich macht man das nie. Und jetzt hat
man Kacktische, die man für nix verwendet. Was muss ich beachten? Ich habe keine Ahnung,
was eine materielle Erörterung ist. Wahrscheinlich. Ich weiß noch nicht mal, was die von mir
wollen. Kein Schimmer. Wir machen morgen weiter. Ich würde sagen, einfach noch ein Argument
zur Übung. Und nächste Woche wird es schon schief gehen. Wir sehen uns. Schönen Tag
noch. Auf Wiedersehen. Was du bekommst, quellen und sollst damit eine Argumentation schreiben,
denke ich. Also quasi, quasi das, was ich mache, wenn ich jemanden auf YouTube flamen
will. Und wenn er was geschrieben hat, dann gucke ich kurz auf Google nach, ob das stimmt
und wenn es nicht stimmt, schreibe ich unten drunter, du Kacknoob, das ist falsch. Oder
sowas. Also im Prinzip, sowas, wie wenn man Flamen-Kommentare schreiben will. Also wenn
man es richtig macht, weil es gibt genug Leute, die flamen einfach, ohne zu gucken, ob das
stimmt, was der andere geschrieben hat. Und wenn man ein bisschen fundierter flamen will,
das ist eigentlich ganz gut, wenn man mal nachguckt. Lösch dich, genau. Bestes Kommen
unten drunter.
Genau, sie sind jetzt an der Schule, zweites Refia-Einsatz in Penzberg bei mir. Also ich
habe bis Mitte August nicht gewusst, wo ich hinkomme. Dann drei Wochen vor Unterrichtsbeginn,
sich nach einer Wohnung umzuschauen, umzuziehen.
Das ist schon fail, oder? Dass das also kurzfristig ist?
Ja. Jetzt würde ich kurz zum Pausenverkauf schauen und mir was Essbares holen.
Okay.
Tag. Dankeschön.
Ich bin positiv überrascht, wie jung die Lehrer da alle sind. Die machen auch alle
den Eindruck, als haben sie zumindest ein bisschen Ahnung, wie man Computer bedient.
Vielleicht ist das auch das Referendar-Büro.
Ich bin dankbar, dass ich verbeamtet bin, aber die Angestellten-Lehrer haben mich auch
ein paar. Eigentlich ist es unfair. Du verdienst halt erheblich weniger. Und das, muss ich
ehrlich sagen, finde ich auch nicht gerecht, weil die die gleiche Arbeit machen und kriegen
einfach weniger Geld dafür.
Morgen.
Und ich habe mal gelesen, dass es sogar so ist, wenn du Angestellter-Lehrer bist, dass
sie dann teilweise so ganz abgedrehte Sachen machen, wie dein Vertrag läuft bis zu den
Sommerferien. In den Sommerferien verdienst du kein Geld, weil du nicht quasi eingestellt
bist. Danach ist teilweise sogar bis ein paar Wochen, bevor es wieder losgeht, in der
WM, ob du überhaupt einen Job hast nächstes Jahr. Hab ich mal in irgendeinem Beitrag gelesen,
weiß nicht, ob das immer noch so ist und ob da was dran ist. Aber ich könnte es mir
gut vorstellen.
Weil Musik kein Vorwirkungsfach ist, das heißt, die könnten rein theoretisch ein Sexanzeugnis
haben und der zählt nicht.
Was? Ernsthaft?
Da liegt die Herausforderung am Lehrer, dass man den Unterricht...
Das war bei mir nicht so. Das war bei mir nicht so.
Du durftest nur... Ich kriege das gar nicht mehr zusammen. Du durftest maximal eine 5
haben...
Wenn ich das jetzt richtig beweise, bin ich mir gar nicht mehr sicher. Ich glaube, du
durftest maximal eine 5 haben...
Oder war das, dass du keine 5 haben durftest? Also ich bin mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher.
Aber durftest du maximal eine 5 haben und solltest du noch eine andere schlechte Note
haben, durftest du die einmal ausgleichen mit einem anderen Fach.
Also keine Ahnung, wenn du jetzt in Musik eine 5 hattest, aber richtig krass in Englisch
bist, konntest du das irgendwie mit einer 2 ausgleichen.
Genau Alfred, genau so, genau so. Jaja, genau so. Also 6 durfte ich nicht. Ich hatte aber
auch nie eine 6 im Zeugnis.
Ich hatte 5, dann hatte ich ein paar. Ich glaube, ich hatte es sogar mal geschafft,
in Religion eine 5 zu kriegen.
Ich habe mich so gestaltet, dass er die Kitze irgendwie packt.
Heute geht es um Casting-Shows.
Erster Arbeitsauftrag. Wer wäre mal so nett und liest mal die Punkte vor. Vater, auf geht's,
hau aus.
Scanne den QR-Code auf deinem Arbeitsplatz. Liese den Artikel, unser grundsätzliches
durch, für der anschließenden Rückentext.
Ihr habt den QR-Code hier, ihr könnt es hier abschneiden.
Alter, das ist ja mal, das ist ja Bleeding-Edge-Technologie in der, ist das, ist das eine deutsche Schule?
Seriously? Ist das?
Ach guck mal, das ist, Kawai ist das, das, das Keyboard, aber, ist das eine deutsche
Schule, ja wirklich?
Ich muss mir mal angucken, in welcher Schule, hat er gesagt, hier, hier, hier, Walter Klingel,
das muss ich, das muss ich mir jetzt mal angucken, was das für eine Schule ist.
Realschule.
Alter, was ne Seite, was ne Seite, man.
Okay, aber mein Darkreader aus.
Na gut, da geht's ja eigentlich.
Das scheint ne ganz normale Schule zu sein und die haben QR-Codes zum Scannen und Rechner
und Monitore und sowas, Elite-Schule des Fußballs, boah, da geht's aber ab.
Das ist doch scheiße, man.
Ihr habt den QR-Code hier, ihr könnt's den hier aufscannen.
Ihr habt gar kein Handy dabei, dann geben wir euch mal eins.
Wie?
Gut.
Krass.
So unkompliziert.
Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, was mich, was mich mehr verwirrt, dass sie kein Handy dabei
haben oder ob die nur sagen, dass sie kein Handy dabei haben, weil sie sich irgendwelche
Vorteile erhoffen, noch dass ihnen der Lehrer das Handy gibt.
Ich, ich, ich würde im Leben einen Schülern immer Handy geben.
Irgendwie sieht er planlos aus.
Irgendwie macht er ein bisschen planlosen Eindruck, der Junge.
Vielleicht täuscht's auch nur.
Warum sitzen die da eigentlich mit Jacke drin?
Können die alle nicht heizen?
Machst du hier noch ein Bindestrich hin?
Danke.
Perfekt.
Ansonsten top.
Gut, dann würde ich an der Stelle unterbrechen.
Okay.
Ich hab mich schon ein bisschen erkundigt davor.
Siehst du, rein, rein Optik hat nichts mit dem wirklichen, von der wirklichen Ahnung
zu tun.
Ich hätte jetzt gedacht, er guckt ein bisschen ahnungslos, aber nein, guckt er nicht.
Corona-Stoßlüft, naja, ah, verstehe, stimmt, das ergibt Sinn.
Schau jetzt nicht so gut aus, hab dann einen Angestelltenvertrag unterschrieben und dann
einen Tag vor dem Urlaub rufen die an, ja, Staatsministerium, Unterrichtung, Kultus.
Meine Mama ist daneben gestanden und ich hab gesagt, ja, nehme ich an und da hat sie schon
gemerkt, ja, nehme ich an.
Ah, jetzt hat er eine Planstelle und dann sie so gleich.
War natürlich mega happy, gleich ganz aufgeregte Stimme.
Toller Moment.
Ich hab sogar einen Streamshot gemacht von der Nummer, ja.
Es geht eigentlich, und das muss man jetzt an der Stelle schon ganz klar sagen, es geht
immer nur ums Geld, immer nur um die Kohle, gerade bei Casting Shows.
Brutto sind es 4.650, netto bleiben im Schnitt, also 3.450.
Ich wünsche euch noch einen schönen Tag, macht es euch gut.
Das ist aber ordentlich.
Ich schau euch beim Start.
Das ist durchaus ordentlich, da kann man sich nicht beschweren.
Verbeamtet bin.
Und wie viel bleibt dir übrig, der muss ja auch weniger Steuern bezahlen.
Ich wünsche euch noch einen schönen Tag.
4.600.
Ja gut, davon bleibt hier natürlich ordentlich was übrig.
Netto bleiben im Schnitt, also 3.450.
Das ist ordentlich.
Ich wünsche euch noch einen schönen Tag, macht es euch gut.
Tschüss.
Tschau.
Dafür würde ich im Leben nicht Lehrer werden, aber wenn man dann gerne Lehrer ist, ist das
glaube ich echt okay.
Start, verbeamtet bin, hab ich weniger Abgaben, weil ich zum Beispiel keine Rentenversicherung
und so weiter zahlen muss.
Hab aber auf der anderen Seite natürlich meine Krankenversicherung, die ich selber bezahlen
muss, privat.
Ja, er ist schon netto.
Also ich mag ihn.
Er kann auch sehr gut erklären und so und wenn wir auch Fragen haben, dann erklärt er
das auch.
Den beiden steht ins Gesicht geschrieben, Kamerateam, lasst uns in Ruhe.
Sehr gut.
Und was macht ihr jetzt noch?
Wir gehen jetzt nach Hause und lernen noch ein bisschen Physik und Geschichte.
Ja, ganz bestimmt.
So, jetzt achtet ihr das, oder?
Erstmal heimlich in die Raucherecke oder irgendwas jetzt.
Schauen wir mal, was das wird.
Neues Thema heute.
Wir beschäftigen uns heute mit der Epoche der Aufklärung.
Oh.
Moment.
Dann ist es doch gar nicht so.
Naja, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Der bezahlt ja auch weniger Steuern.
Weil 60k im Jahr ist dann, wenn du normal Steuern bezahlen müsstest.
Das ist jetzt doch nicht ultra viel.
Aber es ist schon okay, zumal er ja auch nur irgendwie 20% oder so nur Steuern bezahlt
hat am Ende.
Ich hab noch gar nicht angefangen.
Die Schulband, oh, das ist jetzt Monkathos.
Komm einfach direkt an.
Eins, zwei, drei.
Man muss ja selber irgendwie jedes Instrument ein bisschen, ich bin jetzt kein Schlagzeuger
oder ein super Bassist, Gitarre ist jetzt auch mehr schlecht als recht.
Aber so ein bisschen sollte man irgendwie alles beherrschen.
Oh nein, Tossmusik, Tossmusik.
Das hat sich wahrscheinlich so grausam angehört, dass sie das nicht aufgenommen haben jetzt.
Sehr hübsch.
Okay.
Gut, dann seid ihr entlassen.
Bis nächste Woche.
Tschüss.
Geschafft.
Als ich das jetzt vorstelle, dass man da dann von der ersten bis zur zehnten, so wie es
gestern war, drin hockt, da ist schon richtig anstrengend.
Was von der ersten bis zur zehnten?
Der meint die fünfte, oder?
Weil erst ist da Grundschule.
Oder, ach nee, der meint die Stunden, ach so, ich kacknup, der meint die Stunden.
Okay.
Gut.
Also dann, mach's gut.
Geh.
Ciao.
Wir sehen uns.
So.
Thema Auto ist so ein großer Kostenpunkt bei mir.
Also meine Eltern haben auch gesagt, was kaufst du denn so ein Auto?
Alex, also das brauchst du nicht und natürlich haben die Recht.
Und ich fahr gerne unten viel Autobahn und da fahr ich ja gerne mal ein bisschen zügiger.
Warum nicht?
Kann er machen.
Weil er kann sich das leisten.
Echt oder?
Ja.
Wie du beim Parkplatz geheizt bist.
Geheizt.
Der kann sich das leisten, der hat auch genug Geld, demnächst noch Diesel oder Benzin zu
kaufen.
Da kann ich mit meinem Opel Agila nicht mithalten.
Ja, zehn Stunden ist viel zu viel.
Er hat zweimal wegversetzen lassen wollen, hat zweimal nicht geklappt, aber das liegt
doch einfach daran.
256 Kilometer täglich.
Ja, dann hätt ich mir auch ein gescheites Auto, also wenn ich das mach, dann hätt ich
auch ein gescheites Auto.
Wenn ich keine Kinder hab.
Das ist nicht wenig.
Wie lang brauchst du denn da für?
Eineinhalb Stunden einfach?
Ich mein, er fährt 120 Kilometer in eine Richtung.
Was meint ihr, wie lang man da braucht ungefähr?
Eins, eins bis eineinhalb Stunden?
So.
Naja gut, ich mein, das ist ja im Prinzip ganz einfach.
Der müsste im Durchschnitt 120 Kilometer fahren, dass er in der Stunde ist.
Das wird er wahrscheinlich nicht hinbekommen, wenn was los ist.
Also wahrscheinlich ist er morgens schneller als abends.
Großer Fahrtweg, aber irgendwann gibt's schon klappen.
Klasse.
Aber.
So.
Ja.
Aber 1250 Kilometer ist schon ordentlich.
Ja, das ist jedes Mal so.
So.
White people happy.
Dann darfst du ja einmal kurz raus.
Das ist so ein grosses Auto.
Da kann man halt alles neu gemacht.
Da, Weihnachten über Ostern, Pfingsten die christlichen Feiertage, spiel ich halt meistens
mit der Trompete und der Orgel irgendwelche Messen.
Spairische Blasmusik-Besetzung. Da bin ich jetzt seit fast zwei Jahren dabei.
So, Servus! Ich habe ihn mitgebracht.
Sogenannte dicke Backe-Musik, wie man da in Hessen zu sagt.
Servus!
Der kann sich das nicht aussuchen mit der Schule.
Hat er doch am Anfang gesagt, der kann sich das nicht aussuchen?
Der kann sich das nicht aussuchen. Anscheinend wurde ihm das in der Referendarzeit zugewiesen.
Offiziell ein Gehörschutz dabei.
Okay, jetzt kommt erstmal bayerische Blasmusik.
Okay, ich will eigentlich nur gucken, was am Ende rauskommt.
Aber ich glaube, das ist nicht nur bei mir.
Das ist nicht nur bei mir oder so.
Der ist voll, voll into it.
Was ist denn das im Jahr?
3500 mal 12.
Wenn es 12-Monats-Gehälter sind.
Davon kannst du auf jeden Fall leben.
Du musst sagen, der hat einen echt sympathischen Eindruck gemacht.
Ich würde allerdings im Leben niemals Lehrer werden.
Nie, nie, nie.
Kein Geld der Welt würde ich Lehrer werden.
Ja, plus Sonderzahlen.
Nee, gibt es nichts.
Haben die glaube ich nicht.
13-Gehälter.
Ja, gut.
Dafür ist er auch kein Beamter.
Wir haben alles schon geguckt, was interessant war.
Okay.
Oh Mann.
Aber er muss halt auch viel fahren.
Und das kostet auch was.
Aber trotzdem.
Er hat einen echt sympathischen Eindruck gemacht.
Und es hat tatsächlich auch den Eindruck gemacht,
dass er Spaß an seinem Job hat.
Das verfliegt wahrscheinlich mit den Jahren als Lehrer noch,
gehe ich von aus.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass du nach 10 Jahren keinen Bock mehr hast.
Na gut, was können wir uns als nächstes angucken noch?
Moment, das haben wir doch schon gesehen.
Most futuristic advanced automations ever.
Okay, das gucken wir jetzt.
Die Videos von dem Typ gucke ich immer ganz gerne.
Was ich bei dem immer verstörend finde, ist,
dass der irgendwie 25 verschiedene Apps verwendet,
um sein Smart Home zu steuern.
Und da denke ich mir immer, warum machst du dir das Leben so schwer?
But why?
Schauen wir mal.
Ja, und das ist der mit 80 Fernseh daheim, genau.
Der irgendwie da in den Fernseh stehen hat,
da in den Fernseh stehen hat, in extra Kinoraum stehen hat.
Dann irgendwie im Schlafzimmer noch ein Fernseh stehen hat,
im Abstellkammer, im Klo noch ein Fernseh stehen hat.
Aber ist halt irgendwo mitten in der Wüste wohnt.
Also typische Macacona geht nicht.
Okay.
Most advanced.
Naja.
Jetzt mal nicht übertreiben.
Ich hab da schon was gesehen.
Ich hab da grad schon was gesehen, was ich mir niemals hinstellen würde.
Ihr macht nicht so einen Krach immer mit eurer Musik.
All the automations, there are two main things you need to know
about how these automations work.
First is something that I've always wanted.
An echo starting a conversation with me.
Gut, da fängt's schon an.
Das kommt bei mir garantiert nicht ins Haus.
It is nice outside.
Do you want me to open the office window shades?
Yes.
Ich will kein Amazon Echo und auch kein Dot und kein Google Home
und was nicht alles gibt.
Ich verwende nicht mal Siri auf meinem iPhone.
Wie gesagt, ich bin der Meinung, die einzige Daseinsberechtigung,
die es auf dem Smartphone hat, ist vielleicht,
falls man während der Autofahrt irgendwas steuern will
oder irgendwas gucken will oder irgendwas machen will
oder irgendwas anrufen will oder...
Aber ansonsten...
Aber nee, bei mir kommt kein Alexa, kein Google Home,
kein Siri oder sonst was am Start.
Und ich bin eh Fan von Knöpfen und Tastaturbedienung.
Also, ja...
Nee.
That's right.
I can be asked if I want something done around my house.
If I say yes, then an automation will run and make it happen.
If I say no, it will skip it.
That's all great, but what if I'm not in the room
and the Echo is asking a question?
That's where the second part comes in.
I'm able to track which room I'm in,
so the Echo closest to me will always...
Trägt der immer einen Sensor mit rum
oder trägt der immer sein Smartphone mit rum?
Weil die Sache ist die, wenn ich durchs Haus laufe,
ich trag nicht immer mein Smartphone mit rum.
Ich hab das meistens dabei.
Oder seine Uhr und das Smartwatch hab ich nicht, fällt bei mir flach.
Das Smartphone hab ich meistens dabei,
wenn ich jetzt hier aus dem ersten Stock ins Erdgeschoss gehe
und was zu essen oder so.
Aber normalerweise hab ich das nicht dabei.
Es kann ja im Endeffekt nur die Uhr oder das Smartphone sein.
Ich mein, sein Hemd wird es nicht sein.
Ich bin immer derjenige, der spricht.
Ich mach das, indem ich Raspberry Pi in verschiedene Räume
in meinem Haus setze.
Nein, die Raspberry Pi allein machen's nicht.
Die Raspberry Pi müssen ja irgendwas tracken.
Das ist die eigentliche Sache. Was hat er denn dabei?
Wahrscheinlich die Uhr.
Ich liebe die rheimus Pang-UNTR von那我們.
Sie haben Treasury Filter bei uns.
Wir haben die
Chemistry Transmissionsfunäftigung.
Auch das Game Screen,
ohne belly, einenoj-
die Akabäuerl oder die Internet dados.
Der
140zett Victor wie ein
Tumblr-Game everywhere.
Das ist der
dangers reproductive
qualification cover.
Oh, okay.
Nein, nein.
Im Endeffekt erklärt ein Spieler einige der technischen Hürden, die ich während des
Set-up gemacht habe, weil es sehr schwierig war.
Und wenn dir dieses Video gefallen hat, solltest du den Abonnenten klicken.
Okay, los geht's mit den Automationen.
Ich liebe Musik während des Tages.
Es ist nicht ideal, wenn meine Frau nach Hause ist und versucht, mit mir zu reden.
Wobei, was sag ich?
Ich hab Mr.
Robot nicht mal geguckt, außer die erste Staffel und ich fand das Ende der ersten
Staffel so enttäuschend, dass ich nie weiter geguckt hab.
Kann sich noch jemand an alle, die Mr.
Robot erinnert haben, könnt ihr euch noch an diese Szene erinnern, wo dieser Ober-CTO
bei Elliot am Arbeitsplatz vorbeikommt und der dann irgendwie sowas sagt, ich sehe schon,
sie haben den neuesten Gnome, ich habe noch KDE oder irgendwie sowas, sowas in der Richtung,
was komplett, was komplett random ist, einfach, ja genau, das mein ich, das mein ich, wartet
mal, das hier, ja.
Genau, das mein ich, das ist einer der wenigsten Szenen, die ich mir irgendwie gemerkt habe.
Also ganz ehrlich, ich mag Voice Assistants eh schon nicht, wenn die Dinger jetzt aber
anfangen würden, mit mir zu sprechen random, wenn ich in irgendeinem Raum bin, so nach dem
Motto, Max soll ich das Fenster aufmachen, Max soll ich den Fernseher aufmachen, Max
Achtung, das Fenster ist auf, das wird mir schon echt ein bisschen auf den Sack gehen
oder Max soll ich Musik anmachen, also das weiß ich nicht, das wird mich nerven, am besten
sind eh NFC-Tags, einfach Handy dran halten, scannen und es passiert was, naja, naja, naja,
dann gehts aus, lass mich ran, dann gehts aus, ja, oh nein, boah, Mental Overload, zu überlegen,
dass man sich beim Wetter anzieht, oh fuck, das macht mich auch immer so fertig, ja, plotet,
plotet einfach zu überlegen, im Prinzip ist es ganz einfach, ich hab 3 verschiedene Dinger,
die ich anzieh das Jahr über, also nicht 3 verschiedene Kleidungsstücke, sondern 3 verschiedene
Sachen, ja, entweder hab ich irgendwie T-Shirt, Hemd, kurze Hose an oder T-Shirt, kurze Hose
oder ich hab Jeans Pulli an, fertig oder mit Jacke vielleicht noch, also im Prinzip ist
es ganz einfach, scheint die Sonne, es ist über 12 Grad, Pulli und es scheint die Sonne
und es ist über, keine Ahnung, 18 Grad, kurze Hose, fertig und ich hatte sogar letztes,
vorletztes, wann auch immer das war, ich hab sogar mal gewagt auf der Arbeit, als es
richtig warm war, kurze Hose anzuziehen, im Business Stonks Enterprise Umfeld, hat sich
keiner beschwert bis jetzt, wisst ihr was ich bei diesen Häusern, ja, du hast schon,
Super Schurke hat schon ein bisschen recht, wisst ihr was ich bei diesen Automation Videos
auch immer beeindruckend finde, weil ich es nicht hin bekomme, das ist alles so clean
und es ist alles so gestellt, dass du beispielsweise auch Staubsauger Roboter super fahren lassen
kannst, guck mal, das ist alles rechteckig irgendwie, das ist alles schön so in Reihe
und Kliet und alles so hoch, dass es drunter kommt und so, dass es nirgendswo hängen bleibt
und sonst wie, wenn ich mich hier umdrehe Leute, ihr könnt das jetzt nicht sehen, aber
wenn ich mich umdrehe, hinter mir stehen jetzt einfach mal drei Kartons voll mit Zeug, mit
Kabel, mit Geräten, mit Zeugs, was ich bei Amazon bestellt hab mal auspacken muss, mit
altem Zeug, komplett verteilt quer durch das ganze Arbeitszimmer, so, hier würde im
Leben kein Staubsauger Roboter glücklich werden drinne, rechts steht die 4HE Serverkiste
rum, links neben mir steht der Bastel, der Basteltisch, den ihr ab und zu schon gesehen
habt im Video, ja, und die Sache ist halt die, genauso Nutellaschnitte ist bei mir ganz
genauso, genauso hätte ich das vielleicht einen Tag sauber und danach würde das wieder
mit der Zeit weiter zugemüllt werden, aber es ist erstaunlich, muss ich sagen, ich finde
die meisten Sachen finde ich in diesem Chaos, ich hab so, ey, pass mal auf, Lifehack Leute,
Lifehack, wenn ihr auch so ein unordentlicher Sack seid wie ich und ihr einfach nur Kisten
habt, wo das ganze Zeug drinne liegt und ihr manchmal fragt, keine Ahnung, wo hab ich denn
jetzt das, weißt was ich, DVI auf HDMI Kabel oder sowas, dann geht ihr in eure Amazon Bestellhistorie
und guckt was ihr ähnlich bestellt habt, entweder am gleichen Tag oder welche Bestellung
kurz davor und kurz danach gewesen ist und wenn ihr eines dieser Teile findet, von denen
die ihr quasi im Zeitraum um das Produkt was ihr sucht gekauft habt, dann wisst ihr, es
ist meistens in der Nähe, also das ist quasi Reverse Lookup mit, über Amazon History und
nachdem ich viele Sachen tatsächlich einfach teilweise noch im original Amazon Karton nachdem
ich es einmal aufgemacht hab, in einer der drei Kisten, also die Kisten sind tatsächlich
thematisch ein bisschen geordnet, ich hab eine Kiste, die ich regelmäßig wegschmeiße,
also da ist dann, keine Ahnung, kaputtenen Netzteile, alte Kabel und Gedöns drin, ist
eine Kiste, die schmeiße ich regelmäßig weg, das ist Ausschuss, dann hab ich eine
Kiste, da ist, soll man sagen, so Automatisierungstechnik, Krempel, drinnen, ja da liegt zum Beispiel,
keine Ahnung, das Low Energy Mainboard sehe ich jetzt von hier liegen, ich sehe den HC2
aus dem Wohnzimmer, den H2 aktuell gerade drinnen liegen und SATA-Kabel sind auch am
Start oder die Steckdosen da ist zum Flaschen und so, sowas in der Kiste drinnen, so und
in der dritten Kiste ist, also grob Technik-PC-Zeug drinnen, von externer Festplatte, bis,
ich sehe noch ein Seasonic-Netzteil, Wechselrahmen mit SSD und sowas, ja und mein Werkzeug hab
ich ja tatsächlich relativ ordentlich, ich glaub mein Werkzeug ist das einzige, was
ich ordentlich habe, das ist mittlerweile ein bisschen ausgebaut, also das einzige was
ich wirklich geordnet habe ist mein Werkzeug und mittlerweile hab ich hier oben noch was
liegen, hier neben, da liegen zum Beispiel ganze Schrumpf-Läuche und sowas drauf, ja
hier unten ist der 3D-Drucker, also es ist einfach nur noch ein bisschen voller geworden,
das einzige was ich wirklich ordentlich hab ist mein Werkzeug und eine Sache, wo ich
nicht weiß, wie ich da bisher ohne ausgekommen bin, was ich mittlerweile auch noch hier unten
hängen hab ist eine Säge und eine Axt, ich hab erst an Weihnachten gemerkt, dass man
das braucht, ich musste nämlich den Weihnachtsbaum abschneiden und ich hatte keine gescheite
Säge, ich hatte nur noch so ein uralt Ding vom Opa, ich bin kaum durchgekommen, daraufhin
hab ich mir gleich bei Amazon mal Axt und Säge bestellt, braucht man, braucht man nicht
oft, aber wenn man's braucht, braucht man's, so wir gucken jetzt das Video fertig, also
wir waren gerade dabei, dass es für ihn viel zu kompliziert ist sich zu überlegen was
er anziehen soll, oh das wird mich dringern, was Alexa mir vorschlägt was er anziehen
soll, auf die Idee, wär man nicht selbst gekommen, wenn man die Temperatur sieht, oh mann, so
er hat quasi das Denken outgesourced, ja das hab ich auch, das hab ich auch, sieht man
sogar, sieht man das nicht sogar in dem Video, ach nee hier ist das Licht schon an, Mist,
ach hier hatte ich den, ich hatte den Motion Sensor hier noch gar nicht liegen, ich hab
einen Motion Sensor hier in der Ecke liegen mittlerweile, dass das Licht automatisch angeht
wenn ich reingehe, also mich würde das ja allein schon ein bisschen, ein bisschen triggern
irgendwie, dass ich permanent einen Echo habe, der mir beim Arbeiten zuhört und über die
Kamera zuguckt, klar kann man sagen Aluhut auf, mal stellvertretend, ich weiß das ist
kein Aluhut, Aluhut auf, wahrscheinlich passiert eh nix, aber ich bin einfach kein Fan von
Voice Assistants und es ist ja nicht mal so, dass es ganz abwegig wäre, es gab ja genug,
ja Illuminati, es gab ja genug Vorkommnisse schon, wo random Leute Gespräche über Alexa
gehört haben oder wo Amazon dann doch zugegeben hat was auszuwerten und auszulesen und sowas,
also ganz so abwegig ist das tatsächlich nicht und es ist ganz einfach, es ist ähnlich
wie bei Verschlüsselungen, wenn man Sachen in die Cloud lädt, ja ich halte es für sinnvoll
Sachen oder eigentlich für Pflicht schon im Endeffekt, wenn man sensible Sachen in
der Cloud speichert, diese zu verschlüsseln bevor man sie hoch lädt, aber wisst ihr was
noch viel besser ist, anstatt Sachen in die Cloud hoch zu laden und sie zu verschlüsseln,
einfach nicht hochladen und so ähnlich ist das mit Voice Assistants auch, wenn man Bedenken
hat, dass die irgendwie was aufzeichnen könnten oder dass die irgendwelche Sachen leaken,
nicht richtig funktionieren, was auch immer, dann ist die eine Sache, ja man lässt sich
immer wieder von den Herstellern erzählen, oh da passiert nichts, oh das ist alles super
kontrolliert oder man hat einfach keinen, weil wenn man keinen hat, hat man die Probleme
nicht, deswegen ich bin kein großer Fan von Voice Assistants.
Das ist schon cool, das ist schon cool, das muss ich sagen, das ist nice, wobei mich interessieren
würde wie viel davon benutzt er wirklich und wie viel hat er einfach nur weil es cool
ist.
Was ist cool ist, dass einige dieser Automationen sehr gut funktionieren, auch wenn ich nicht
in einem Raum mit einem Raspberry Pi bin.
Zum Beispiel habe ich eine Automation, die mich erinnert, um ein Film zu sehen, wenn alle
Kinder in den Bett sind und ich den Projekter noch nicht aufgeschaltet habe, dann sitze ich
hier oder wastee mir Zeit auf Social Media, also das Echo wird mich fragen, ob ich...
Okay, auf einem seiner 5 Milliarden Fernsehgeräten, oder was sonst?
Willst du einen Film in der Theater-Ruhr sehen?
Wenn ich ja sage, dann wird alles aufgeschaltet, um etwas zu sehen, das ist super.
Alternativ, alternativ könnte man auch einfach in diesen Raum reingehen und dort was starten,
also okay, der Beamer muss kurz booten, okay, ja, das dauert vielleicht zwei Minuten.
Also die einzige Push-Notification, die ich von Home Assistant benutze ist, wenn man das
Hoftor auf und zu geht.
Oh nein, das sind halt Probleme, die hast du auch nur wenn du Sachen automatisiert
hast, normale Leute haben das Problem an sich nicht, siehst du, deswegen, also das ist tatsächlich
sinnvoll, ja, deswegen versuche ich mich auch auf Automatisierung und Features zu beschränken,
die wirklich das Leben einfacher machen, ja, zum Beispiel, dass wenn ich vergessen habe,
ein Fenster zuzumachen, dass mir das seine Push-Notification aufs Handy schickt oder
so, oder dass ich Push-Notification kriege, wenn die Hoftür geöffnet wird, oder, wenn
ich eine Anzeige habe, ob die Bahnverspätung hat oder solche Dinge, oder zum Beispiel,
dass die Beleuchtung angeht im Flur, da habe ich ja so eine LED-Leiste, die Beleuchtung
im Flur geht an, wenn Sonnenuntergang ist und sowas, ja, das sind so Sachen, da muss
man sich nicht großartig darum kümmern und da kann eigentlich auch nicht viel schief
gehen.
Wie viel Arbeit ist es eigentlich so ein System zu maintainen?
Das geht tatsächlich, wenn du die Technologien ausgesucht hast, die nicht permanent gestreichelt
werden müssen und am besten offline ohne China-Chinesen-Cloud funktionieren.
Die Thermostat-Bedrohung ist aktuell auf 72°C, die Thermostat-Bedrohung ist aktuell auf
74°C und es beginnt Musik zu spielen.
Die Automation beginnt nur, wenn es soll, und es ist wirklich hilfreich.
Wir lassen die Geräte nicht aus Verlangenen öffnen, und wir hören meistens Musik, wenn
wir Geräte ausverlangen.
Diese Automationen können anhanden sein, wenn ich eine Weile im Zimmer sitze.
Z.B.
Ich war lange in der Arbeit, das Wetter ist schön und die Schäden sind geschlossen.
Das Echo fragt mich, ob ich die Schäden für ein schönes, natürliches Licht in der
Ruhr habe.
Schades ist, naja, ich hab den Rollladen eh nicht unten tagsüber. Er wohnt mitten in der Wüste, er braucht das wahrscheinlich.
Was wirklich cool wäre ist, wenn man, wenn man irgendwie die Möglichkeit hätte, ein irgendwie, wie soll ich sagen, so ein Erholungsmodus, nee, das ist falsches Wort, so zu triggern das, was weiß ich, dass ich alle halbe Stunde einen Knopf drücke, dass ich dann mal kurz was trinke und das Fenster aufgeht, ein bisschen frische Luft reinkommt und dann wieder automatisch zugeht.
Aber ich kann meine Fenster nicht automatisch auf und zu machen lassen. Also ich meine damit nicht den Rollo, sondern wirklich mal frische Luft reinlassen.
Und die Klimaanlage funktioniert ja auch nicht mit frischer Luft, weil das hat mir der Chat erklärt, ich wusste das auch gar nicht.
Meine Klimaanlage hat so eine Funktion um, wie nennt man das, so Antiallergiefilter. Also du quatschst die Klimaanlage an und der kann dann irgendwie polen und so aus der Luft grillen, dass man nicht allergisch darauf reagiert.
Und das ist aber keine Frischluft. Wer kennt denn nicht den Polenfilter? Das ist aber keine Frischluft, sondern das ist die Raumluft, die da durchgezogen wird, dann wird die irgendwie elektrisiert oder so und dadurch fackeln die Polen ab und dann kommt das wieder in den Raum.
Das wusste mir der Chat erklären, dass ein Polenfilter nicht automatisch für Frischluft sorgt.
Ich dachte nämlich das wäre Frischluft, ich dachte kurzzeitig man könnte mit der Klimaanlage tatsächlich lüften. Kann man aber nicht.
Oh ne, please, please, no, nein, das ist ja die grinschigste Automatisierung aller Zeiten.
Der Typ, der guckt echt den ganzen Tag, hat er Musik an, hat er Fernseher an, hat er Alexa-Gestellts am Start, also das ist ja wirklich komplette Reizüberflutung Deluxe hier.
Also eins finde ich bei seinen Set-ups tatsächlich cool.
Vieles ist Spielerei und eigentlich ziemlich unsinnig, aber dass er in jedem Raum ein Dashboard hat zum Home-Automation-Steuern, das finde ich gut.
Vor allem auch eins, wo du nicht anlocken musst, das finde ich gut.
Ich hab unten im Flur ein Dashboard hängen, oben im Flur ein Dashboard hängen und natürlich das Smartphone und die Tablets und so, die so im Haus rumliegen, aber in jedem Raum so ein dedikater Dashboard, das finde ich cool, das hat was.
Das ist Home-Assistent, ja, 100 Prozent.
Ja, aber Room-Detection funktioniert nicht so ohne weiteres, Room-Detection funktioniert nur, du musst halt irgendwas bei dir tragen, dass es dich detekten kann.
Haben die Dashboards Mikrofone?
Wahrscheinlich.
Das blöde ist am NS-Panel, dass es keinen Browser hat zum Anzeigen, deswegen fällt das für mich als Dashboard flach. Man braucht einen Browser, damit man seinen Home-Assistent-Dashboard anzeigen lassen kann oder die Home-Assistent-App.
Ne, das ist ja nur Nachbau davon, das ist ja nicht dein normales Dashboard. Oder? Ne, ist es nicht, das ist nur Nachbau, ne, das bringt ja nix.
Ja, das stimmt.
Okay, siehste, der macht es nicht über die Uhr, der macht das über sein Handy, das heißt, du musst, dass das funktioniert und er dich detektet, du musst überall und immer dein Handy mitnehmen. Das mache ich nicht. Mein Handy hängt jetzt hier gerade am Ladegerät und wenn ich jetzt mal aufs Klo muss, eine Runde Pepo-Pupu oder so, dann würde ich dann eben mein Handy mitnehmen.
Der NFC-Tag am Wäschekopf scannt sich von selbst, ne, den kann ich da nicht scannen. Wenn ich das Handy nicht mitnehme, kann ich den nicht scannen, klar.
Verstehe, ich nehme oft genug mein Handy mit aufs Klo, aber ich will nicht davon abhängig sein, dass ich mein Handy mit aufs Klo nehme, damit das ordentlich funktioniert.
Okay, naja, also so der Wahnsinn war das jetzt nicht. Weiß nicht, also.
Der Chip unter die Haut funktioniert ja nur passiv. Ah, du könntest dir einen NFC-Ding quasi unter die Haut injecten und dann bräuchtest du irgendwelche aktiven Geräte zum Scannen.
NFC scanst du halt nicht mit einem Raspberry Pi quer durch den Raum, um zu gucken, ob einer da ist. Das funktioniert nicht. Da brauchst du irgendeinen Low-Energy-Bluetooth-Beacon oder so, dann wird das funktionieren. Und dazu brauchst du halt eine Smartwatch oder ein Handy, was ich nicht immer mitnehmen will. Und Smartwatch verwende ich keine.
Gibt's empfehlenswerte Android-Tablets? Gute Frage, nächste Frage. Ich hab mir bisher nur ein Android-Tablet gekauft und das hat mich auf kompletter Linie enttäuscht. Erstens das Gerät selbst und zweitens der Update-Support.
Ich hab mir irgendwann mal ein ASUS ZenPad oder so gekauft. Irgendein älteres, irgendwie sowas hier. Das wurde nie richtig geupdatet und der Rahmen war auch viel zu klein und es war einfach undurchdachtes Gerät. Ich muss sagen, bei Tablets muss ich sagen eindeutig iOS-iPad.
Die gehen preislich auch, finde ich. Man muss sich ja nicht gleich die 1000-Euro-Variante kaufen. Und bei Smartphones kann man sich drüber streiten.
Wie gesagt, ich hab mittlerweile so viel Unterschied. Ich hab alles möglich im Einsatz. Ich hab jede Menge Android im Einsatz, jede Menge iOS-Sachen im Einsatz. Und das hat alles seine Vor- und Nachteile. Man muss die Geräte dort benutzen, wo sie ihre Stärken ausspielen können. Fertig. Es hat keinen Sinn, Hardcore-Apple-Fan zu sein oder Hardcore-Android-Fan und Hardcore-Microsoft-Fan oder Hardcore-Playstation-Fan. Man muss das nehmen, dort, wofür es gut ist.
So, was gucken wir uns sonst noch an? Playstation 3-Emulationen ist impressed. Das funktioniert doch eh wieder zu helfen, richtig?
Was ist deine...oh nee, das Simplicissimus kann ich mir jetzt nicht anrufen. Das ist wieder alles so super dramatisch.
100.000 RPM mit Lego-Dingern. Okay, Sack. Ein Lego-Video pro Stream muss sein.
Ich lass mal die Musik an, sonst schlaf ich ein dabei wieder.
Es hat keinen Sound, das Video. Gibt keinen Sound. Sound overrated, outdated, debated.
Ah, jetzt. Kogas!
Okay, es ist nicht powered bei einem Lego-Motor.
Es gibt jetzt die Übersetzung auf Doom hier.
Es gibt die Übersetzung auf Doom.
Boah, das flutscht.
So viele Kogas.
Also eins ist klar, das Ding da oben macht es nicht so lang.
Wow, 20.000, gleich hebt es ab.
Okay, das kann ich abheben, das hat keinen Propeller, aber das flutscht, flutscht.
Ich glaube, wenn das da abfliegt irgendwie, und du keine Brille auf hast oder so, das
kann ins Auge gehen.
Ah, gleich mal das Sägeplatt dran gemacht, dass wenn es ins Auge geht, auch richtig ins
Auge geht.
Was hat er da eigentlich für ein richtig Pogas-Messgerät?
Okay, ich weiß, was es macht, die Umdrehungen messen, aber wie nennt man sowas?
Tachometer, das haut schon ganz schön rein.
Okay, mehr Übersetzungen, zu wenig, zu wenig Übersetzungen, gib ihm.
Mehr Übersetze, bald vibriert das Ding so, dass es auseinanderfällt.
Wow, weg ist es.
Das fliegt gleich raus.
Okay, bei 40.000 Umdrehungen sind wir schon mal, alles klar, alles klar.
77.000, Hauptsache er hat ein Handschuh an, da kann er sonst nichts passieren.
Hört sich ein bisschen nach Zahnarzt an, das stimmt.
Okay, mal gucken, wie schnell er es kriegt.
Ah ne, da will er dafür sorgen, dass es nicht runterfällt, okay, frei fährt.
147.000, sag mal, ab wann pulverisieren
dann Lego Zahnräder?
Die sind ja nicht dafür gemacht.
Okay, wir haben es gleich geschafft Leute.
Aber, also lang kannst du das nicht machen, dann hast du alle deine Lego Zahnräder pulverisiert.
Oh oh, ich dachte gleich fliegt es weg, aber jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Oder auch nicht, aber ja, so Chat, was gab es denn eben noch?
Habe eine Tastatur bei Aliexpress bestellt, sollte ich mir Sorgen machen, dass sie nach
Hause telefoniert?
Ha, das ist schwer zu sagen, China-Chinesen-Kram, potenziell kann da durchaus ein Controller
drin sein, der dann Sachen keylockt und irgendwo entschickt, das weiß ich ja nie.
Ich würde mir aber eher weniger Gedanken zu machen.
Wie viel RAM hast du eigentlich am Start?
Ich glaube 32G.
Haben wir gerade auf Reddit gelesen, es gibt einen Bug in Battlefield 2042, das ist ja
was ganz Neues, dass das US-Team am Russen spawnen und andersrum sterben natürlich alle.
Bei diesem Game wundert mich nichts mehr, wirklich gar nichts mehr, da wundert mich
gar nichts mehr.
Warum?
An sich wäre das überhaupt kein Ding, die einfachste Variante, was mir einfallen würde
ist, den Keylogger in die Tastatur einzubauen, also Controller zwischen Tastatur und USB
und theoretisch kannst du ja dann eine SIM-Karte rein machen, die das verschickt.
Das haben die Chinesen wahrscheinlich nicht gemacht, aber es wäre relativ easy.
Der Controller musste es schon selbst versenden, über den PC geht das nicht, ja das stimmt.
IoT-SIM-Karte, aber was dir halt passieren kann ist, dass sich das Keyboard nicht per
USB-Keyboard am Rechner anmeldet, sondern als Massen-Storage-Gerät mit Autostart oder
irgendwas, also da gibt es ja zig Tausend Möglichkeiten das anzugreifen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das passieren wird über den AliExpress-Keyboard, ganz ehrlich,
glaube ich nicht.
Ich habe auch so viel AliExpress-Zeug schon bestellt, aber das ist der Grund, warum ich
es immer Custom-Firmware-Flasche, da kann man sich dann sicher sein, dass nix drauf
läuft was man nicht haben will.
Can we reach Speed of Sound, das gucken wir uns das nächste Mal an.
Wahrscheinlich ist es, dass die Tastatur einfach nicht geht, das stimmt, wobei ich sagen muss,
ich habe da bei AliExpress immer gute Erfahrungen gemacht, wenn was nicht funktioniert oder
wenn Versand nicht klappt oder sonst wie, du musst das nicht zurückschicken, die schicken
dir einfach was Neues, musst halt drei Wochen wieder drauf warten.
Was hältst du von mechanischen Tastaturen, finde ich eine super Geschichte, ich habe
auf der Arbeit schon lange eine mechanische Tastatur und hier bin ich mir gar nicht sicher,
ob das eine mechanische ist, hier von Logitech, glaube aber schon.
Hast du das ADC-Zeug eigentlich jetzt verstanden, ich habe gestern Discord nicht mehr gestartet,
ich habe überhaupt nicht mehr dran gedacht, heck wait, Leute ich muss mich hydraten, Hydration
ist raus, gut, haben wir noch irgendwas, was gibt es denn spannendes Leute, gibt es irgendwas
das wir noch unbedingt angucken müssen.
Hydration, nope, nope, nope, ah mein Zahnarzt wieder, nope, nope, nope, gucken wir uns den
jetzt an.
Du hast ein was für ein Ding, ein Royal Klatschge Akriege, was für ein Ding, ich könnte mir
gar nicht vorstellen was das sein soll, ah das ist eine Tastatur, Royal Klutge, Zetge,
Aha, und warum ausgerechnet die, die hat schon mal keinen Num Block, das gefällt mir nicht,
ich mag meinen Num Block, ich mag meinen Num Block, gibt es die auch mit Num Block, Royal
Klutge, wie spricht man die denn aus, Emma Saying, ok Emma, Gludge, Gludge, Gludge oder
Glatsch, alles klar, Royal Glutsch, was auch immer, hast du dir schon mal die Gaming Möbel
von, was, nein, wusste ich gar nicht, dass sie das haben, komm mal, wenn du die Möbel
hast, dann hast du automatisch einen Föhn, der deine Haare beim Spielen pustet, Höhenverstellbarer
Schreibtisch, schon mal eine gute Idee, Höhenverstellbarer Schreibtisch ist immer gut, gut, der Stuhl
kommt wahrscheinlich nicht, Uts Pelare, Gaming Stuhl, sieht aus wie typische, die Armlehnen
scheinen mir etwas weit unten zu sein oder, wozu brauchst du Armlehnen, die gefühlt
irgendwie 10 cm hoch sind, Mauspads, dann lieber den, wenn man das hochstellen kann,
ich mag meinen Höhenverstellbar Tisch, ich verwende es zwar relativ wenig, aber ich
finde es gut, Moment, was ist denn das, wait a minute, das ist sowas, was ich auch bei mir
in der Werkzeug, für meine Werkzeugwand habe, aber ich wäre nie im Leben auf die Idee gekommen,
dort Controller und Tastaturen dran zu hängen, aber die Idee finde ich gut, ich meine, warum
nicht, ja, ich finde das nicht schlecht, warum nicht, und was haben die sonst noch so, Rock,
die dürfen natürlich nicht fehlen, Asus, Gaming Stühle, Gaming Tische, Gaming Zubehör,
Gaming Tisch und Stuhl Sets, also im Prinzip haben sie nur Tische und Stühle, was wirklich
interessant ist, ja, dadurch, dass das rot ist, das muss hier Rock, Rock Design sein,
oh, warum ist das so viel teurer als das andere, aber als Höhenverstellbar ist, muss sagen,
schockt mich jetzt nicht so krass, irgendwie, ja, hier haben die diese Boards, wisst ihr,
wofür das gut ist, wenn man viele Kopfhörer hat, dann könnte man die dahin machen, Ring
leuchte mit Mobiltelefonhalter, Becherhalter, dumme Frage, warum kann man den Becher nicht
einfach auf den Tisch stellen, warum muss der in den Becherhalter, weil man Angst hat,
ihn umzuschmeißen oder weil es cooler ausschaut, irgendwie haben wir gerade ein Bild von Reddit
geschickt, okay, das ist nicht, weil man es braucht oder, das ist nicht, weil man es braucht
mit der Tastatur, das ist im Endeffekt einfach, um zu zeigen, was für ein geiler Hecht man
ist und wie viele Tastaturen man hat, sehe ich doch richtig, oder, Becher mit Deckel
und Trinkhallen, naja, na gut, also, ich denke, das Zeug ist wahrscheinlich weder besser noch
schlechter als die anderen Sachen, die da so für Gaming verkauft werden, ich persönlich,
ich habe hier meinen Office Stuhl und meinen stinknormalen Tisch mit einer Holzplatte,
ohne dass das in irgendeiner Art und Weise Gaming beworben ist, es funktioniert auch,
ich würde sogar behaupten, es ist eine ganze Ecke besser, wenn auch vielleicht ein bisschen
teurer, ansonsten, ich habe es mir gekauft, ich habe es noch nicht gespielt, ich glaube,
ich gehe jetzt auf, muss mal ein bisschen den Hals schonen, ich gehe nächste Woche
wieder arbeiten und ich will nicht, dass es wieder schlechter wird, ich bin kein großer
Dark Souls Anhänger, aber Eldring spricht mich tatsächlich immer an, Arbeiten ist Pains
Champ, das ist wohl wahr, ok Leute, wir sehen uns, also, wir arbeiten, geht, cringe, ja,
wir sehen uns, bis dann, machts gut, see you.